so today I'll be presenting a talk on
the implementation and Analysis of deep
learning models for code switch speech
classification
I know my name can be a tongue twister
for a lot of people out there so here is
the nickname of me uh you can also call
me yashi if you find it difficult to
call me by my real name and yeah I'm
currently working as an associate data
scientist at Avi in Bev India with good
background in research projects and
contributing to open source uh projects
like numpy and I have contributed a lot
in the python communities and mostly in
the diversity and inclusion space
before getting started with the session
I would like you to walk through the
agenda with me so first we'll be going
through the problem statement and the
background
followed by an overview of the solution
that was picked up to solve this problem
then we'll be diving deeper into the
data collection and processing
techniques
after that we'll have a look at the
whole pipeline of the process of the
convolutional neural network audio
classification that was taken and post
that will have a look into the pipeline
of the recurrent neural network or audio
classification
after all of this we'll have a look at
the summary and the resources that was
used uh while I was doing this project
so as I told that I have like done a lot
of research projects back at my
University so this is also one of the
research projects that I did there
so code switching is a condition in
which a speaker tends to alternate
between two or more languages in the
context of the same conversation or
situation
now this is something which is very
common in countries wherein people speak
uh at least speak two languages or more
than that and they tend to often you
know switch uh go back and forth between
uh those languages while in their
conversation
even in the automatic speech recognition
uh system which is used in the devices
like Alexa Siri this is a challenge
which is definitely uh solved by a lot
of research which is already going on in
this area
but yeah it Still Remains a challenge
because of the growing globalization and
in countries like India wherein people
uh tend to know at least two languages
they often code switch while they are
conversing
so here's an example
so uh the words marked in blue are Hindi
and the words marked in pink would be
English so as you can see the first
person says
a Hindi phrase of asking how are you and
the other person replies he who that
he's fine you tell how things are going
so both the people tend to go back and
forth between two languages and that's
exactly what is code switching that is
happening
having a look at the solution so in this
project I have taken Hindi and English
as the two monolingual languages along
with the code switch data
so first and foremost we went along with
the data collection since the data that
we required for this was not very
readily available out there in the form
of data sets so we have to manually
collect the data after that we did the
data preprocessing techniques uh using
the different python Library especially
librosa
through which we extracted the important
features
uh that would be ultimately used for
building the CNN or the rmin model so
the feature of Mel spectrograms used for
CNN model and the Mel frequency sexual
coefficients was used for RNN model
after creating these models uh it was
set on the training and the testing
training data trained on that and then
it was tested where it would classify
the audio into either Hindi English or
code switched
let's dive deeper into the data
collection and the pre-processing
techniques
as I told that this data was not very
much readily available out there as we
can find on kaggle or some other website
so we were provided with a recording
extension from our college and with the
help of family and friends we were able
to record the conversations and then we
were able to get some data from the
reality TV shows that go on so this way
we created a data set of 25 hours with 5
000 samples of code switch data that was
Hindi and English mixed and 2 000
samples of English and 2 000 samples of
Hindi so each and every sample was of 10
seconds long and it was in dot wav
format
for pre-processing except for the python
libraries like numpy sklearn librosa was
the go-to package for pre-processing the
audio data
this is the package that basically
helped us to get the important features
like Mel spectrograms and Mel frequency
sexual coefficients so yeah
coming to the convolutional neural
network
now uh it was seen that uh like while we
were researching uh for me to make this
project we discovered that beta audio
data a simple raw audio data or
spectrogram images uh the convolutional
neural network would identify and train
well on is that but it was much better
to go for a spectrogram since it's a
concise snapshot of the audio signal
and it is a better option as a for a
data because it in the convolutional
neural network if you provide a image
data that would train much better on
that so that is how we came down to the
spectrogram as the data that we would
provide
after extracting the spectrogram from
the different audio signals that we had
we realized that it was not having a
much better heat map that it should have
so that it the CNN can train well on
that now what spectrogram does is that
it creates a graph using the Fourier
transform and a Fourier transform what
it does is it decomposes the audio
signal into different frequencies and
then these frequencies are mapped
against the amplitude and that's how a
spectrogram is formed
so since this was not giving the result
that we expected we went up to the Mel
spectrogram now what is Mel spec program
uh this is a very common thing that
humans tend to hear frequency which is
lower like 100 Hertz 200 Hertz and we
tend to identify the difference between
them so if there's a voice of 100 Hertz
and 200 Hertz will be very easily uh be
able to identify the difference between
the two sounds
but if the frequency goes higher like
let's say 10 000 Hertz and 10 000 and
100 Hertz
we won't be able to identify the
difference between those two frequencies
because the frequency is very high we
might not be able to completely hear the
sound also
so this is the thing that we tend to
identify the difference between two
sounds not on a linear scale but on a
logarithmic scale
so this thing was solved using a Mel
scale which is there in the research
papers that we went through and on that
Mel scale basis only a male spectrogram
is formed which gives a much better heat
map for the convolutional neural network
to function upon
so we extracted the Mel spectrograms and
then the convolutional layers were
pulled uh for the quality purposes it
was pulled around the labels uh the
three different labels that we had
they had numerical labels for Hindi
English and code switched 0 1 and 2. and
for that then the model was prepared
around these labels and the data points
as Hindi English and code switched
after fully training the model
it was set on the testing data set and
it clearly identified uh whether which
the sample that was provided was which
language
so here is a pipeline of the whole
process that was uh adopted in the audio
sound as you can see here uh the above
graph is the signal graph that is given
there that is the data that we get after
that the signal in real time graph then
the graphs that you see below these are
the two heat map graphs of male
spectrogram as you can see that they
give a much better visibility of the
Audio Waves and through this it was
identified that a few unique regions in
these heat Maps they correspond to a
particular label so on this basis the
CNN was able to identify to which label
it could map that particular sample and
this way the whole model was trained on
these male spectrograms the Audio Waves
converted into male spectrograms
then this as you can see the
convolutional neural network was formed
and it was it identified the test data
into three different classes of Hindi
quotes West or English
then we went forward with recurrent
neural network so this was the Second
Step that we got
so here as male spec program was being
used in the case of CNN for RNN Mel
frequency substrate coefficients was the
feature that was extracted using leprosa
so uh these features uh were stores uh
stored along with the labels in an ampi
array which was then normalized
here to form the RNN we use the lstm the
long short term memory for the
remembering purposes and then it was
compiled and it was trained on the
training data set that we had
after that the classification was done
on the three labels as it was done
earlier in the CNN model
here is a pipeline of the RNN
classification
first the audio sound that was taken
into account the different uh samples
that we have the 10 each 10 second
sample in dot wav format then the signal
in real time the signal graphs were
extracted after that the Melt frequency
septal coefficients were calculated
using numpy and then the data
preprocessing was done basically it was
cast into an Empire array along with the
labels and then the data was normalized
after this the RNN model was created
using the long short term memory and
then it classified the uh
the test data set into the three
categories here is a graph of the mfcc
coefficients which is plotted against
here are these summary and the resources
that we basically used for our research
study that we were doing in the uh while
building this project so
you can go through them uh they
basically uh tell you the basics of what
is a melt scale on which a male
spectrogram was formed and how is male
frequency sectional coefficients
calculated so it is very important to
exactly know the math behind of it
because since Mel scale has like a whole
mathematical
calculation and after that uh the speech
recognition with deep recurrent neural
networks this was a research paper
through which we went which basically
told us how the rnm function and what
all we can Implement then audio
recognition using the male spectrogram
and convolutional neural networks so
this was basically
a research paper through which we were
able to uh exactly make out how male
spectrograms are helping the CNN and why
exactly they are a better choice over
spectrograms this was definitely a great
paper to go through
and then the neural model for language
identification in code switch tweets so
this was not exactly
um uh related to our a project but since
it was looking into the code switch data
and initially when we came to the
problem statement we were not really
sure what we were dealing with so this
was a good uh
introduction as it provided us what
exactly is code switching and how it is
being solved in different areas like
here it was it is
so uh you can get in touch with me
either on Twitter
I wasn't happy to guide you in the areas
that I have previously worked upon and
thank you
thank you very much
uh we have a question now
foreign
can you see the screen or
uh no I'm not able to seriously uh shall
I stop sharing mystery
uh maybe if you I'm not sure I can read
the question for you no worries
uh so um
Narendra is wondering if you also tried
1D CNN's not sure what the input
features there would be but in Time
series tasks they are sometimes set to
combine the best parts of CNN's and rnns
okay yeah so this was something that uh
we are still uh exploring because uh
initially we were only exploring the
Deep learning areas and we came to know
like the the CNN and the ironing model
have different uh ways of going in this
space so we uh basically went in uh
diving deeper into like how exactly only
CNN solves the problem and then the RNA
all right
we still have a sometime for extra
questions
so we have a question from Conrad
um can you also talk more broadly about
any differences you saw with English
versus Hindu uh Hindi and or other
languages ASR
so uh ASR is different so what happens
is like uh automatic speech recognition
systems was what while we were exploring
we uh saw that here is a challenge
wherein people uh at like it is not
specifically on Hindi or English but uh
on the code switching part that uh like
they have to identify like let's say if
I talk in Hindi or I might talk in any
other language which might not be a
global language right so uh that's what
not we were exploring here but this is
definitely a challenge in ASR but there
was a difference in the pattern of the
Mel's Fair program on which the CNN was
based
okay we have another question from
ganish
and is your project and data available
on GitHub to check
okay so uh since this was a research
project and it was uh basically for my
college so sharing a code would be a bit
confidential so that's why I'm here to
point to share the resources that I used
the primary resources though we went
through a lot of stuff but these were
the few resources that I found the most
useful while preparing it
um I can share even more of them um
after the talk
okay great
you can still have
a few questions feel free to ask
foreign
any plans to make your own ASR iot
device any future plans for your
research
yeah definitely I would be open to
research but I have not decided to
either I want to you know go on the
device making or I would further explore
uh on like how to optimize these models
and yes create
um my own personal project so that I can
publish it on GitHub so definitely I'm
open to research uh and yeah I would be
doing that
look with your endeavors
thank you
we can wait for another minute uh in
case any questions came and if no
questions are available we can wrap up
the talk
foreign
did you try running the models with data
that contains noise like English and
Hindi spoken by a non-native speakers
so uh mostly the data that we obtained
here was uh like the Hindi part was
spoken mostly by the native speakers so
and the English definitely it was not
native um uh it was mostly the Indian
people recording it so the Indian
English
so uh there wasn't uh if you talk about
the noise
so no data noise was there exactly but
yeah at times when you record the data
and the exact words that you want right
like the the language basically but
there's uh there can be a background
noise and all that can basically make
the data muffled and uh so that purpose
will have to clean the data before you
ingest it in a model or something
otherwise the feature extraction here
would not be accurate at all so that you
have to make sure while you're curating
the data uh though that's uh the most
initial part the data collection but
that is the most important part because
you need to make sure the data that
you're ingesting in the model is Right
otherwise it would be garbage and
garbage out right
so yeah